ROMAN NURIK: Hello,
and welcome to
Android Design in Action.
My name is Roman Nurik, With
me here today is--
ADAM KOCH: Hi guys, Adam Koch.
And over in London--
NICK BUTCHER: Hi,
Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: So today, unlike
most days on the show--
most Tuesdays on the show--
we're not actually going to be
talking about redesigns.
So for those of you who have
never seen this show, we
usually take a look at apps
that have been nominated--
usually the developer nominates
themselves--
and take a look at how we can
reimagine some of the screens
in those apps to fit better with
Android styling, and just
be a better experience
for users overall.
And then we take that, and we
pass it off to developers and
see if they like it.
And if they do, then sometimes
they make the changes.
And sometimes, they don't.
And for those of you who have
been watching, basically,
developers can come back on
Thursday and let us know what
they think of the show.
And that's the Developer Strikes
Back, where developers
strike back show.
This week, however, we're
not doing any of that.
Because of the massive technical
failures that
plagued the guys in Mountain
View for the Friday app
clinic, we decided to take a
slightly different approach to
this episode today.
So today, we're going
to be talking
about responsive design.
So let's jump into what
responsive design is.
Now, for several people, this
is the first time they're
hearing of the concept
of responsive design.
And Ethan Marcotte--
and sorry, Ethan, if I'm
mispronouncing your name--
Ethan Marcotte coined the term
a few years ago in an article
that talked about responsive
web design.
And basically, you can see from
the quote here-- this is
from the article--
it's really about taking a
website and making sure that
it scales across any medium, be
it phone, tablet, browser,
different screen sizes,
and pretty much any
other device type.
So taking a single layout or a
single piece of content and
making sure that it scales
according to its medium.
So that's responsive
web design in
a super small nutshell.
So responsive web design
applies to
mobile apps, as well.
And so today, we're going to
be talking about responsive
design and how it applies
to Android devices.
Before we jump in, Adam,
Nick, any comments?
Any thoughts?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, as you were
saying, we're focusing on
responsive design, because this
week, we're having a big
focus on tablets.
We've just launched some quality
guidelines on how to
make a high-quality tablet
application.
And, for me, having an
application which scales well
on the huge variety of devices,
that is the Android
landscape, is a big, big
part of that quality.
So I think this is a really
important topic.
ADAM KOCH: And one quick thing
I wanted to mention was I
really believe if you kind of
think about these responsive
web design or responsive Android
development from the
beginning of your development
cycle when building Android
apps, it can help you get that
tablet app or create designs
that just really make it easier
to suit all different
screens out there.
So rather than just designing
from the ground up, if you
just think about all these
things from the beginning, it
really helps.
ROMAN NURIK: And before we jump
in again, just to talk a
little bit about the format,
we're not really going to be
talking about development
best practices.
We do have several training
sessions on
developer.android.com
on how to actually
implement these concepts.
But what we will do is we will
look into existing apps that
are out there and see how they
treat or how they implement
these responsive designs, how
they kind of scale fluidly
across the different
device types.
So let's jump in.
First, we're going to take
a look at Calendar.
So this is the built-in calendar
application that
comes with many devices, like
the Galaxy Nexus, the Nexus 7,
the Motorola Zoom.
And this is an example of the
screen that lets you create a
new calendar entry.
So on the phone here,
you see that--
and I'm going to go zoom
in for a second--
on the phone, you see that you
have a kind of Done, Cancel
bar at the top, which is
basically replacing the Action
bar, and the different entry
fields, like the Calendar,
Event Title, the Date, Time,
things like that.
Pretty typical stuff.
And then on the Nexus 7, you'll
see that it's switched
over into kind of a multi-column
layout where on
the left column, you have the
labels of the different text
entry fields.
And on the right, you have
the fields themselves.
And then on the 10-inch
tablet in landscape--
I'm going to zoom in here.
Sorry about that.
You'll notice that it's
basically the same screen as
the screen in portrait, except
it has wider margins.
So basically, they've decided
that, let's make sure that the
content, the text fields never
go past a pretty common
number, around 45 to
75 characters.
Let's make sure that you can
never see more than that all
at once so that the line lengths
aren't too long.
So to fit that constraint,
let's introduce
margins along the sides.
So that's, in a gist, in a
nutshell, what the Calendar
app's Create Event screen
looks like.
Guys, any thoughts on other
things that they've done
really well here to make sure
that this is responsive?
NICK BUTCHER: I'd probably
just like
to call out as well--
we talk a lot on this show about
Holo, about the visual
language of Android, the Holo
visual theme, and that it has
its own certain flat
look and feel.
And I just wanted to call out
why that-- it's not an
accident that that kind
of design scheme
was chosen for Android.
And I think this set of
screens here really
demonstrates how Holo helps you
to create a user interface
which scales nicely by using
typography and spacing
appropriately to give your
application structure, which
you can clearly see in
these three screens.
That there isn't a lot of Chrome
subdividing boxes and
so on, text boxes and so on.
It really is the content
which defines the
structure of the page.
And that really, really
helps it to scale.
You haven't got lots and lots
and lots of different bitmap
assets or graphical assets or
gradients all over the place,
which may look strange when
scaled up and wouldn't really
help you out in this field.
So I think this is one of my
major takeaways from looking
at the Calendar application is
how Holo really, really, helps
out this app to scale across
these screen sizes.
ADAM KOCH: And one quick point
for me, if you look at the
white space on the margins--
let's see, if we zoom in here.
So you can see on the phone,
you've got some white space on
the left and right.
And then if you go up to the
Nexus 7, you'll see there's
slightly more white space.
And then if you go across to the
landscape zoom, you'll see
they've actually got more white
space here that sort of
makes everything fill out the
larger screen size there.
ROMAN NURIK: It's important to
know that when you're creating
or defining these margins that
you still stick to a grid.
And as you can see in our design
guide under the Metrics
and Grids section, we have this
concept of a 16-DIP grid
and a 48-DIP rhythm.
So using increments of 16 DIPs,
so 32 DIP or 48 or 64,
that can still introduce
structure into your layouts
without constraining you to just
using very small margins.
So 32 DIPs, 48 DIPs, that's
great to use for larger
devices, such as tablets.
NICK BUTCHER: Yes.
A naive implementation of this
kind of screen might have just
stretched the input fields all
the way across, which would
look pretty ungainly
on the 10-inch.
So I think it's approaching your
screen design when you're
designing an app.
And if you see something which
is so barren, thinking about,
hey, how is that going to look
on a much wider display, like
a 10-inch in landscape, for
example, and bearing in mind
where you might want to
start introducing
these margin points.
ROMAN NURIK: So let's move
on to the next app.
So this will be the first
third-party app
that we look at.
And this is Pattrn.
Nick, you want to talk a little
bit about Pattrn?
NICK BUTCHER: Sure.
So Pattrn is a great little app
for finding wallpapers for
your device.
It's by a UK developer called
Lucas who works for Mozilla.
And I think they've done a great
job of really making the
content adapt.
Luckily for them, they have
almost a dream application for
this kind of scenario where the
content-- the patterned
wallpapers--
have no kind of concept
of aspect ratio or
anything like that.
They actually kind of tile, so
it works really well that they
can change for different aspect
ratios, which might not
be the case for some apps.
But as you can see, in the three
screens we're showing
here, on the phone, they're
relying on three tabs to go
through the three major
views of the data.
But when they get beyond a
certain point and have more
space, they actually break that
out away from the tab
navigation into having this
sidebar, which I think works
really well.
Rather than just stretching the
content to be overly wide,
it actually gives you easier
navigation, as well as
servicing more information.
So you can see there on the
Nexus 7, for example, it
services recent searches.
So it's kind of one tap away.
Rather than having to tap into
the search field and then get
shown the recent history, it
might prompt you to click on a
recent search, which
is really great.
The other thing, if you look
at the difference between,
say, the phone and the 7-inch
tablet, is they've actually
hinted the text size and
paddings to be slightly larger
to just feel more comfortable
at that certain size.
And then--
ROMAN NURIK: And it looks
like-- sorry, Nick--
it looks like on a tablet,
they have just a slightly
wider margin.
I don't know if it's an
increment of 16 DIPs, like we
talked about, but it's
definitely noticeably larger
to the left and to the right
of the patterns.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, and then
just last thing I can say,
when you step out from the 7-
to the 10-inch and have even
more space available, they break
out into this kind of
grid view where they show more
potential wallpapers
on screen at once.
So it's kind of reimagining
the content, the
representation of the content.
So it's the same content but
laid out in a completely
different way to just make much
better use of the space.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, and I just
wanted to comment on one
missed opportunity.
And this is very minor, but
if you look at the handset
version in landscape-- we don't
have a screenshot here--
but Lucas also uses a single
column for the patterns.
So since he's already got
multi-column implemented, it
seems like it would be fairly
trivial to switch that over to
a multi-column-- like a
two-column layout in landscape.
That might work really well.
OK.
So let's move on to the next
app, unless you guys have any
more comments.
ADAM KOCH: Just one question.
I haven't actually used this
app that much, but what's
under the You tab for
the handset version?
[INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN NURIK: Nick--
I actually don't remember
myself.
I think it was Favorites
and something else.
But it was a combination
of either one.
ADAM KOCH: So I guess it's just
interesting to note how
they've definitely changed the
structure just a little bit on
the handset version just so they
can fit it into the three
standard tabs there and make
it still look nice.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
OK, let's move on.
So we should do a time check.
OK.
So the next app is Pocket.
And Pocket is-- actually, I
think it's called Pocket,
Formerly Read it Later.
Pocket is basically a--
it's a saved list of articles.
So if you're browsing an RSS
feed, and you don't want to
read it right now, you just go
off and save it to Pocket.
And they have an intent that you
can share to and all those
good things.
So this is kind of the main
screen in Pocket that lets you
see the list of your
saved articles.
So you'll see that on the phone,
they have a simple list
with thumbnails on the right.
Now, when you scale that up to
a 7-inch tablet, they have a
two-column grid, and if you turn
that over into landscape,
you'll see that there's
a three-column grid.
And you'll notice that it's
completely different, but it's
the same content, right?
It's more of like a tile view
rather than a simple
horizontal linear layout.
And then if you look at the
10-inch tablet, they've
basically graduated into more
of a quote, unquote,
"magazine" layout, similar to
how the Google Play client
application lays out the
different tiles in the
featured sections.
So the interesting thing to me
is that they've done a lot of
work here to tweak font sizes.
So you'll notice that the title
sizes on the 10-inch
tablet are slightly larger than
on the 7-inch tablet.
And then the fact that they've
basically implemented this
layout three times, once as a
list, another as a grid view,
which is probably a simplified
version of the magazine layout
on the right.
But they also have the magazine
layout, which we
don't have framework
support for.
One of the things I should note
is that they may have
cheated a little bit.
They may be using WebView in
HTML5 and CSS3 stuff to do the
layout, which is perfectly
awesome.
The only issue is that there's
some minor performance
penalties--
well, maybe not minor, but there
are some performance
penalties involved.
But overall, it looks
just wonderful.
Yeah, so that's in a nutshell.
The other thing I wanted to
mention is that they kept the
action bar the same.
And this is totally fine.
You don't necessarily have to
switch the action bar and make
it taller, make things wider.
The framework actually does
all those things for you.
It'll make your icon slightly
wider, the action
bar slightly taller.
So it'll do all those
things for you.
In this case, I think that
they've probably implemented a
custom action bar, so it's
not happening there.
But note that the action bar is
pretty much the same across
tablet and phone, in terms
of behavior and rough
proportions.
NICK BUTCHER: One of my favorite
things that they've
done on here as well is that you
can see on the phone and
tablet, they've prioritized the
search, bringing it out
right at the top of the content
view so you can search
and filter, whereas on the
tablet, they have kind of
demoted that.
So less important.
I think it's under the action
overflow there, which I think
is really interesting.
I think it's shown that they've
thought about how
someone's going to use this
application slightly
differently on a tablet, that
they have the same content
available, but it's a different
representation.
They're kind of designing for
a different use case where
someone might have more time
and might be in more of an
explorative mode.
ROMAN NURIK: Any
other comments?
OK, so let's move on to--
I believe the--
oh, no, there's TED.
Talk about TED, Adam.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, so the TED
app-- hopefully, some of you
are familiar with the TED app
and all of the great content,
video talks that they have.
So I like this example just
because it's fairly simple.
You don't have to do anything
crazy or complicated in order
to support different form
factors and have it look nice
and feel nice still.
So if you look at the three
different form factors that
were posted up here, you've got
the handset in portrait
mode, where they have the big
thumbnail at the top and then
three subtabs down at the bottom
to show the different
views related to that video.
And then you move to Nexus 7,
which looks fairly similar.
They've added some extra
white space.
Let's just zoom in here
a little bit.
They've added some extra white
space, notably around the
tabs, as well, which
is interesting.
But otherwise, it's
fairly similar.
Extra white space, slightly
bumped up font size.
And then, if you move to
the landscape 10-inch--
let me zoom across here--
you'll notice that they've moved
from the sort of stacked
layout of their fragments
to being side by side.
But essentially, it's
the same fragments.
You can clearly tell
they've reused the
same fragments there.
One interesting thing for their
video thumbnail here is
they've moved the title from
being a transparent overlay to
beneath the actual video,
because there's more room, and
they can really bring out the
nice video thumbnails,
allocating a little bit
more space for that.
Guys, you have any comments?
ROMAN NURIK: I just wanted to
mention one thing about the
overall structure
of the screen.
It reminds me of the YouTube
playback screen on Android.
And I think that that's
actually a good thing.
I think that users, when they
buy their Android device, they
pop open YouTube, they instantly
become familiar with
how it behaves.
And I'm guessing if
you rotate into
landscape, it's full screen.
They're very familiar with how
it behaves, kind of the tab
structure at the bottom on the
phone that lets you switch
between the different
pieces of detail
information about the video.
And then in tablet, they
basically do something, again,
very similar to YouTube.
They pop that over
to the right.
And this is almost like a
natural way to do something
with the new space
that you have.
But I just that added extra
bit of similarity to the
YouTube app makes it instantly
familiar to users.
Nick, anything else
before we move on?
NICK BUTCHER: I would say
they've done a great job of
playing with the spacing
as well.
I think you can see that they
definitely hint at the spacing
when you go from phone up to
7-inch to make it just feel
that much more comfortable
on that sized device.
So it's the kind of thing where
you might have just
tried the phone layout on the
7-inch device and thought,
hey, that's good enough.
But they've actually gone the
extra mile to say, actually,
it feels a little bit cramped or
would benefit from a little
bit more spacing here.
So they've gone the extra mile
to really optimize for the
different device sizes,
which is great.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, it's worth
noting as well that they don't
have a landscape layout for
this particular screen on
handset devices.
Actually, I'm not sure if they
actually have landscape for
any of the screens on handset.
But for a video app, especially
for a video detail
screen like this, I think that's
OK sometimes, because
people sort of expect that when
they rotate, the video
will be playing full
screen instead.
There's not really enough room
to do much else there.
That's TED.
ROMAN NURIK: OK, so let's
move on to, I
believe, the last app.
So we're kind of cheating here,
because this is an app
that we all worked on.
This is the Google I/O
2012 application.
So basically, this app, if you
attended the conference, it
lets you see what sessions
are playing.
It lets you create a
personalized schedule.
It also syncs across your
different devices, which,
again, is very important for a
multi-device user that has
multiple devices, having
seamless sync across those.
So what we've done here
is basically--
on phone, there isn't that
much horizontal space.
So we have three tabs for the
different core pieces of
functionality.
That's kind of the interaction
side where you interact with
other people on Google+ that
are also attending the
conference.
The My Schedule or My Agenda
area, and then the exploration
phase, where you can look at
the map or take a look at
individual tracks.
So the interesting thing that
we've done here is we split it
up from tabs to multiple
panes across tablets.
So in portrait, actually,
both of these devices--
7-inch and the 10-inch
device--
in portrait, they would show
this kind of two-column
layout, where two of the panes
are stacked in one column.
And in the landscape, they
switch to a wider
three-column layout.
One of the key differences
between the 7-inch and 10-inch
layouts here is that the
margins here on a
7-inch are 16 DIP.
And here on a tablet that's
10 inches, they're 32 DIP.
And that actually gives a little
bit more breathing room
for the content on this
10-inch device.
And you'll notice this on the
next screen as well, once we
get to it, that this adds
a sense of spacing and
separation of the two pieces
of content, or in here, the
three different pieces
of content.
Any thoughts, guys?
NICK BUTCHER: It's
a beautiful app.
ADAM KOCH: Whoever designed
this is amazing--
[CLEARS THROAT]
Roman.
ROMAN NURIK: One thing I forgot
to mention is that you
can't see this in the
screenshot, but these tabs on
phone, as you swipe across
them, there's actually a
16-DIP divider that has-- it's
actually just empty space.
That divider is the same grey
background as is on the
tablet-- so in this area.
So if you have multiple devices,
there's a subtle hint
that these are actually part
of the same screen.
So as you slide on a phone, like
I said, you see that grey
background giving you, again,
that sense of separation.
ADAM KOCH: One last thing.
One thing I really like,
personally, is on the tablet
layouts, the sort of alignment
of the headings of each of the
different fragments,
it just makes the
app feel really nice.
And as Roman was saying, it's
got this sort of padding, the
equal padding there between the
different sections here
and also the little ticker,
which I can't remember what
it's called.
ROMAN NURIK: The What's
On fragment?
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, the
What's On fragment.
It just sort of-- the
alignment there
looks really nice.
Makes everything look
really consistent.
ROMAN NURIK: One thing that we
haven't done here is use
Roboto Thin or Roboto Light,
which we probably should have.
So in case you want to make the
title stand out even more,
get even more attention--
I'm not convinced that it's
necessary here, but you could
use a large point size and
Roboto Thin to give an elegant
header to each of these panes.
OK, so let's move on to the
second screen in this app.
And this is basically the
session detail screen.
So once I get into a specific
session, like in this case,
the session that Chris and Ellie
gave on Android apps and
Google Play where they
announced the
new publisher console.
Once I get into the screen,
there's a bunch of information
that I may want to see, a bunch
of actions that I may
want to take on the session.
For example, I may want to add
it or remove it from my
schedule, share it with people,
see a map of it,
things like that.
I may want to +1 it up here.
And I may want to see the list
of speakers, learn more about
Chris or Ellie, and
then there's a few
links at the bottom.
So what we've done here is this
is a single screen on--
well, the session detail and the
list of sessions, which is
a previous screen.
This is a single screen on
phones, whereas on tablets,
it's combined into a
multi-pane layout.
This is kind of the very common
master detail layout
that's used in almost all
of our system apps.
You'll notice that
in portrait--
it's not really visible here.
We kind of need animations.
We don't have the fancy
technology to show this.
But in portrait, it's kind
of a sliding screen.
So that left pane collapses
once you start interacting
with the right detail pane.
And then pressing the Up button
slides it in again, or
it's just actually sliding
on the screen.
And then in 10-inch tablets on
landscape, we have all that
space available, so we don't
need that collapsing behavior.
So it's always visible.
Any thoughts, guys, on other
things we should point out?
NICK BUTCHER: I really the
treatment on the 7-inch here,
where it's not quite wide
enough to have the same
displays you have on the
10-inch, to have all the
information permanently
on screen.
So it's a nice solution with the
sliding in and out to give
you a lot of the benefits of
having both on screen.
I like the quick interaction
between swapping between the
current sessions, rather than
having to do it on the phone,
where you have to keep on going
up and down, back up to
see the other adjacent
schedules.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, one minor
thing, which I like, is
there's this concept
of links related to
a particular session.
So these are dynamic links
related to a session that fall
below on the handset and--
let me see if I can zoom--
in Nexus 7 version.
But then if you go to the
10-inch version in landscape,
you'll see they sort of fall
alongside the content instead.
So it's just--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, that gives
a great way to get a natural
margin point, as well, so that
the details don't get too
wide, I think.
ROMAN NURIK: I think one of
the natural points here is
really just about text length
and white space.
You really want to optimize to
minimize large, large swaths
of white space, where there's
just nothing on screen.
You don't want to throw
information along one of the
edges of the screen
or the corners.
And then, like I said about the
line lengths, you want to
really optimize around a certain
number of characters
per line, because any larger and
it's a little less easy to
read in terms of your
eye having to
jump to the next line.
And then any smaller, it's
kind of like a newspaper,
where if there's only two or
three words per line, it
becomes really tedious
reading a vertically
long piece of text.
So really that's one of the
optimization points, is to
make sure that the text itself
is very legible and that the
white space is adequately
filled.
One last thing I wanted to point
out is just a common
thread across these-- you'll
notice that the green
background maintains some of
the branding for the track.
So you'll notice that the
action bar icon here is
colored green to indicate you're
looking at Android.
And then the green is persistent
across the
different tablets.
All right.
So with that, let's move on to
our last section, since we
have four minutes left.
Wow, we're on time, guys.
That's awesome.
Since we have four minutes left,
let's jump into Android
Design News.
So the first bit of news-- and
this is not really news.
Sorry for lying to people.
So this is actually an article
from Kirill Grouchnikov, who's
one of the engineers on one of
Google's very popular apps.
He wrote a series of articles
on responsive mobile design.
They're more like, I guess,
developer focused, but they do
focus a lot about the different
switching points,
the margin points, as Nick was
alluding to, and how you make
those decisions, and then,
basically, how that affects
your different layouts
on tablets.
A little caveat that this is
a little over a year old.
So some of the thinking is
the older version or the
predecessor of what our current
design thinking is.
But it's a phenomenal intro to
responsive mobile design.
Moving on.
Nick, I think this is yours.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, this is
fantastic to see that this is
one of the applications, which
we took a look at two weeks
back, called Glimmr, which is
an application for viewing
photos from Flickr.
And just want to say good job to
the developer, Paul Bourke,
who's taken the designs and
implemented them already.
You can see the change here in
the before and after of his
first screen.
So no longer is it just a plain
login, but he actually
shows up some content right
from the beginning, and it
looks really nice.
I think he's done
a wonderful job.
So good job, Paul.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, totally.
Well, good job, Nick,
as well, for
inspiring the initial designs.
Next is The Verge.
Nick, do you want to talk
about that, as well?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, sure.
So The Verge, popular gadget, my
go-to gadget news site, has
just done a Holo redesign.
So you can see here, they've
stayed pretty faithful to the
Holo look and feel while
marrying it to their branding
quite successfully, I feel.
So generally, a really
nice job.
A few issues with the navigation
in the application.
But they've done a good job, and
I'm also really pleased to
see them use the drawer
navigation
pattern pretty correctly.
So that's very good to see.
ROMAN NURIK: Next we have
ActionBarSherlock.
And this is more focused
toward developers.
But ActionBarSherlock is a
library by the very famous
Jake Wharton.
It's a library that lets you use
the action bar in all of
its glory on devices that don't
really have Honeycomb or
Ice Cream Sandwich yet-- for
example, Gingerbread devices.
And the latest version--
version 4.2--
adds, I believe, it's
preliminary support for
SearchView.
So if you've been designing
around SearchView because you
must support Gingerbread, this
may be a good way to
backport that view.
And I think that's
it for this week.
I think we're one
minute early.
But again, thanks
for tuning in.
And we hope to see you next time
where we will actually be
doing redesigns of video player
apps that are reviewed
this Friday, I believe,
on the app clinic.
Thanks again.
As always, I'm Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Adam Koch.
NICK BUTCHER: Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: Signing off.
See you guys later.
ADAM KOCH: Thanks, guys.
Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]